en el último vídeo nosotros tratamos de
introducirnos poco a poco en una
definición común pero rigurosa de lo que
es un límite y dijimos que cuando
hablamos del límite de fx cuando x se
aproxima a c es igual a él y nosotros
realmente lo que estamos diciendo con
esto que ella es una definición un tanto
rigurosa se puede obtener que fx sea tan
cerca como tú quieras de l haciendo que
x sé lo suficientemente cercana hace
ahora para hacer esto un poquito más
generalizado vamos a poner tan cerca
como tú quieras le vamos a llamar que es
un número positivo llamado épsilon dicha
épsilon es la letra griega que nosotros
conocemos pero vamos a tratar de
realizar esto más como si fuera un juego
entonces supongamos que dijeras que tan
cerca quieres esto ya hace del juego que
mejías que tan cerca quieres que fx este
dl y hacer esto es dar un número
cualquiera positivo al cual llamaremos
épsilon donde épsilon va a representar
los cercanos que va a estar fx
l entonces vamos a señalarlo aquí que al
dar un número positivo llamado épsilon
va a ser que tan cercano va a ser que
tan cercano queremos que esté fx de l
por lo que por ejemplo que dijeras que
épsilon fuera igual a 0.01 y esto es lo
cerca que lo quieres estaría diciendo
que quieres que este punto 0 1 cerca de
él y entonces lo que hemos estado
haciendo es decir ok dado un número
positivo que ya tenemos el cual es
épsilon ahora vamos a encontrar otro
número positivo el cual vamos a llamar
delta y también como en el otro caso
utilizaremos la letra griega delta y de
tal manera que si x está dentro de el
intervalo que se encuentra o sea que de
tal forma que x se encuentre dentro del
intervalo que va a formar delta y c
luego entonces luego entonces f x va a
estar dentro de el rango del intervalo
que va a estar entre
el dado épsilon y nuestro límite que en
este caso es el y ahora veamos que en
realidad dicen la misma cosa esta
definición amarilla de aquí nos está
diciendo que puedes obtener f x tan
cerca como tú quieras de él haciendo que
x quede lo suficientemente cerca de c y
en esta segunda definición nos estamos
refiriendo un poco más hacia el juego
donde alguien dice que tan cerca quiere
que esté f x de l con el epsilon dado y
luego hay que identificar la delta pues
hay que ver qué tan largo queda el
intervalo de x 11 entonces ya después
efe x estará dentro del límite y es lo
que hacemos aquí mira nosotros aquí lo
que quisimos es construir x que tuviera
un cierto tamaño de tal manera un cierto
rango de tal manera que éste f x se
proyecte en el intervalo que nosotros
quisiéramos y déjame realizar esto un
poco más claro por el diagrama que
dibuje por aquí entonces dices que
quieres que fx tenga épsilon como límite
por aquí entonces esto va a ser él
+ épsilon y el límite de por acá va a
ser el menos eps block y luego dices ok
seguro yo pensé que podría hacer que fx
estuviera dentro de este rango como
nuestro límite y podemos hacer esto
definiendo un cierto rango alrededor de
ese y esto podría ser déjamelo dibujo un
poco más claro esto podría ser
encontrando otro número positivo otro
número que sería delta por lo que esto
de aquí va a ser déjame primero trazó
las líneas punteadas esta de la
izquierda va a repetir la derecha va a
representar hace más delta y este de por
acá va a hacerse menos ya me equivoqué
déjamelo borrar va a ser menos delta y
este es el rango que ha definido en el
eje de las equis y como nosotros sabemos
fx o nuestra función no está definida en
ce así que hay que tener cuidado de
tomar un equis que quede en este rango y
este próximo hace más no se hace y
entonces podemos tomar cualquier equis
en este rango y efe de alguna de estas
equis va a quedar tan cerca como hayamos
puesto
nuestro límite y esto el límite va a
quedar dentro del l + épsilon y el menos
épsilon por lo que en otras palabras lo
que estamos diciendo es que dado un
épsilon vamos a encontrar un delta por
lo que vamos a hacer esto un poquito más
matemático o un poquito más riguroso
entonces vamos a escribir el mismo
párrafo pero en un lenguaje mejor y
entonces vamos a comenzar tenemos que
tenemos que tenemos un número positivo
no o mejor dicho dado un épsilon lo voy
a escribir de esta forma para que quede
bien dado épsilon mayor que cero podemos
encontrar estos en la primer parte del
enunciado podemos encontrar o existe un
delta que también va a ser mayor que
cero tal que tal que si encontramos que
x se encuentra en el intervalo que hay
de c + delta y c - delta que es el que
pusimos por aquí o bien en otras
palabras para accent irá mejor la
distancia de x menos se lo voy a poner
en valor absoluto para que nos
represente la distancia es menor que
delta y este término lo que nos está
diciendo es que cualquier x que se
encuentre en este intervalo de s más de
13 menos de alta va a ser menor que
delta puesto que si lo tomas dicho x en
alguno de estos puntos pues sí va a
terminar siendo y las restas la
distancia que haya con se va a terminar
ciento menor que delta entonces luego
tenemos que también la distancia que hay
a la distancia vamos a encontrar que la
distancia de fx como nuestra función
menos el límite está expresando su
distancia será menor que épsilon y todo
esto lo que nos dice es que es que si
ciertamente el límite existe es que si
tú me das un número positivo épsilon y
éste puede ser cualquier número súper
pequeño nosotros podemos encontrar a
delta podemos encontrar a delta y un
rango que esté alrededor de c y todo
este término nos está diciendo que la
distancia será menor que delta donde
delta puede ser también cualquier punto
de por aquí pero en cuanto a éstos
efe es de x la función respecto a esas x
va a estar dentro de este rango que
específica nos va a estar entre los eps
y long como nuestro límite pues la
diferencia que hay entre fx y nuestro
límite que es l será menor que épsilon y
las ff x estarán situados en algún lugar
de por aquí en algún lugar de este rango
y finalmente esto es todo lo que
respecta en cuanto a la definición del
límite con épsilon y delta si en el
siguiente vídeo vamos a tratar de
demostrar que esto existe